Yeah, bro. Logic, you got it. 10
minutes.
>> All right. What does it mean to be true
God?
>> It has no meaning. That's something that
Christianity makes up.
>> Oh, so you don't believe that Allah is
the true God?
>> It's kind of incoherent when there is
only one God.
>> It's incoherent. Hold on, bro.
They found clay tablets predating the
Hebrew Bible by centuries. They revealed
the biblical prophets were quoting
canonite myths and legends about
polytheistic worldview and gods.
They're probably upsetting me now.
>> What does the word true mean?
>> Something that's true.
>> You just use the same word in the
definition.
>> And the cowardly thing about this is
when we first agreed to this debate, I
made it clear to you that this debate
was not going to be about some arbitrary
Christian definition of God by nature.
Now we're at the point in the debate
where he's now crying about the prompt.
Ladies and gentlemen, Abu Norori, this
was his best argument against
Christianity. And dared to challenge me
on this topic. And so now that this has
been utterly destroyed intellectually,
intellectually, now all OF A SUDDEN, OH,
NOW HE'S COMPLAINING about how we're
defining God and how I'm proving the
point and it just you concede it. It's
over. Okay.
Um, are demons gods?
>> No.
>> By nature?
>> Okay. Does the Bible say that the gods
of the nations, the surrounding nations
are demons?
>> The Bible contradicts itself. No, it
doesn't necessarily say that because
when we read your Bible, we find
instances where um your Bible says that
the devils, I believe in uh Hebrews 1:5
says that when demons sin, they are cast
into hell until the day of judgment with
cl uh with gloomy chains. So, these
can't be demons. Why are these demons up
in heaven kicking it with your God?
>> All right, this is Deuteronomy 32:17. It
says, "They sacrificed to demons who are
not God, to gods whom they have not
known, new gods whom came lately, whom
your fathers did not dread." Does the
scripture say that the nations that they
sacrificed to, these gods they
sacrificed to are actually demons?
>> Yes. So, we see here that the Israelites
or the author, um, whoever the author is
is anonymous. Whoever this author is,
he's trying to cope. What's going on is
he's already quoted from the, um, Ugaric
text. He's already stolen from the
scriptures. And we know historically and
academically, we're going to get into
this later, that it's known historically
that the Israelites were polytheist at
first and they later adopted monotheism.
So, this is a later attempt at a
cleanup.
>> Does the author say that the nations the
gods the nations that they said were
gods are actually demons? Does he say
that? Yes or no, please?
>> Yes, that is verbatim in the Bible, but
we can't take away from the fact that
other places in the Bible show that they
aren't they aren't they are demons.
Thank you.
>> Gotcha. I appreciate it. Thank you so
much. So today we're talking about the
multiple gods that are present in the
Bible. And when I say multiple gods, I'm
not talking about judges. I'm not
talking about kings, rulers. I'm not
talking I'm talking about gods flying,
floating around, throwing thunderbolts.
My opponent who wishes to refute this
cannot simply offer us some type of
theological
uh theological guessing maybe this
workaround. It doesn't work like that.
He has to show us textually that these
things are untrue and that there aren't
real multiple gods in your Bible that
interact with your God Yahweh. Because
by definition, monotheism,
a monotheist is one who believes in but
one God. A heenotheist is someone who
only worships one God but believes in
the existence of other gods. They don't
deny their existence. And he h
heenotheism flirts with polytheism and
it is not monotheism. So the question
comes back to are there multiple gods in
the Bible?
>> Here's Deuteronomy 32:17 which he's
going to going to he's going to try to
go to later on. It says they sacrificed
to demons that were not God to gods they
had never known to new gods that had
come recently whom your fathers had
never dreaded. According to the Bible,
are these true gods by nature? No. These
are demons that they that they're
worshiping, demons that they're
sacrificing to. Let's keep going.
Jeremiah chapter 2:1, it says, "Has a
nation changed its gods even though they
are no gods?" Uh-oh. Looks like the
Bible is explicit that these things that
they worship, these objects of worship,
these idols, uh, these gods of the
nations are not actual gods by nature,
but our demons, our idols are worthless.
Let's keep going. For all the gods of
the peoples are worthless idols, but the
Lord Yahweh made the heavens. You guys
see that? Now, let's make this clear
because I I like to I like for us to see
the name of God. So, this so this, you
know, can't be any mistake here. So, in
not in Psalm 96, it says, "But Yahweh
made the heavens, for all the gods of
the peoples are idols. They're nothing.
They're worthless. They don't actually
exist. That's what the Bible that's what
the Bible authors are teaching. Let's
keep going, guys. Galatians 4:8.
However, at that time when you did not
know God, you were slaves to those which
by nature are no gods. What What are we
doing here, man?
What What we doing here, Bill? Boy, what
what is this? According to the Bible, it
is explicit. It's it's not hinting.
There's no confusion. According to the
Bible, these gods are not gods by
nature. Rather, they are demons, idols,
figments of imagination, nature. Let's
keep going. 1 Corinthians chapter 10:20.
Watch what he says here. No, but I say
that the things which the Gentiles
sacrifice, they sacrifice to demons and
not to God. And I do not want you to
become sharers in demons. The Bible is
explicit. The Bible is clear. There is
no other God other than the true God,
Yahweh. So, here's Deuteronomy 32. So,
in the measureetic text, they've
actually altered it from its original
reading. The Dead Sea Scrolls, which is
to the right, has the original reading.
If there's nothing to see here, why are
the transmitters of the Bible corrupting
your Bible and changing what it says?
So, let's read what the Meseretic text
says. It says when the most high gave
the nations their inheritance when he
divided humans he fixed the borders of
people according to the number of the
sons of Israel. The issue is that this
is talking about the tower of babel in
Israel wasn't even a thought. Let's read
the dead sea scrolls which the
septuagent also agrees with. The
septuagent excuse me the dead sea
scrolls reads when Elan gave the nations
their inheritance. When he divided
humanity he fixed the borders of the
people according to the number of the
sons of God. the baneo Elohim. The very
next verse says Yahweh's portion is his
people Jacob, his allotted inheritance.
So we see here two things. We see here
that Yahweh is inheriting from Eljon.
Eljan didn't say he was going to divide
the nations amongst himself and the Beno
Elohim. He said he was going to divide
it amongst the Ben Elohim. Yahweh
receives a portion. No problem. Who are
these Beno Elohim that receive nations
to be gods over? Mr. logic.
>> Let's go to Psalms 82 very quickly.
Psalms 82 says what? God Oh, let make
sure you guys can see it. We don't want
you to miss nothing. God takes his place
in the divine council. So, this council
is divine. There goes the essence that
Mr. Logic is looking for. In the midst
of the gods, he holds judgment. In the
midst of the gods, he holds judgment.
For how long will you defend the unjust
and show partiality to the wicked?
Defend the weak and the fatherless.
Uphold the cause of the poor and the
oppressed.
Rescue the weak and the needy. Deliver
them from the hands of the wicked.
The gods know nothing. They understand
nothing. They walk about in darkness.
All of the foundations of the earth are
shaken. I didn't know humans shake the
foundation of the earth.
I say ye are gods. All sons of El Yan.
Why does Eljan keep popping up here?
Ye are sons. Son, you are I say ye are
gods. Sons of El Yan, but you will die
like mere mortals. What do you mean I'll
die like a mere mortal? I thought these
were just regular people. He's saying
that Elleon, the most high, like I said
before, is giving Yahweh Israel. That he
gave Yahweh uh Israel. Now, here's the
thing about this. Nowhere does it say
anywhere. Nowhere does it say that uh
Yahweh was given Israel. It doesn't say
that. It just says that Israel became
Yahweh's inheritance. That he inherited
Jacob. That's all. And like I said, let
me read again. He says the author
intentionally
avoided the active verbal form meaning
to give. like he like we see Elon giving
to the rest to giving to mankind setting
the boundaries. He actively avoided that
when it came to Yahweh saying so so as
to not say that Elon gave Israel to
Yahweh
but only says Israel became the property
of Yahw. You'll find this in L and
Yahweh in his journal of semitic studies
volume 1 page 29. So even the scholars
are understanding that there is no way,
shape or form where Deuteronomy is
teaching or Deuteronomy 32 is teaching
that Elellon is some separate deity or
higher deity that is supreme over Yahweh
and Yahweh is like the son of Elon. That
is just stupid. We talk about who's
dividing the nations who who what what
what's happening here in Deuteronomy
chapter 4 verse 19 to 20. Watch what it
says. And lest you lift up your eyes to
heaven and see the sun and the moon and
the stars, all the host of heaven, and
be drawn away and worship them and serve
them, those which Yahweh your God has
aortioned for all the peoples under the
whole heaven. But Yahweh has taken you
and brought you out of the iron furnace
from Egypt to be a people for his own
inheritance as today. Wait a second. I
thought Elon gave this to Yahweh. Why is
it here saying that Yahweh took them
upon himself? And why is it here saying
that Yahweh has a portion for the
people, these other these other gods
that they like? You can you can have all
this. You can have these worthless eyes.
You can have the sun and the stars and
the moons or whatever, but y but Israel
is mine. Israel is going to worship the
true God. They are going to know the
true God. I thought it was Elon, a
separate deity who did that. Abonori. So
why is it here saying that it's Yahweh
who divided THE BOUNDARIES? IT'S YAHWEH
who picked out Israel for himself.
Genesis 14:22, it literally says that
Yahweh is Elon, the most high,
right? Yahweh is Elon, the most high,
the possessor of heaven and earth. Psalm
97, for you are Yahweh, Elleon
over all the earth. Where are we getting
confused here? The Bible is explicit
that Yahweh is Elon. Yahweh is the most
high. So stop with this goofy argument
that you're saying like you're talking
about goofiness. This is goofy beyond.
There's levels to this. There's levels
to this. Stop this. Stop it with this
nonsense. Now when it comes to Psalm 82
again, Psalm 82, the fallen Elohim, the
fallen angels, the fallen Elohim who are
still identified as the sons of God.
Still identified as the sons of God who
were rebelled against him. who who uh uh
uh went against God, who judge
unrighteously, who are unrighteous, and
and Yahweh judges them. So what? Nowhere
in Psalm 82 does it ever say that they
are God by nature,
that they are the creator, that they are
the uncaused cause, that they are
everlasting.
Never does it say that in Psalm 82. And
so when it says here that the that God,
what you admitted here, you admitted
that the God who is inheriting the
nations, who is inheriting the nations
is Elon, the most high. You acknowledge
that. My question to you would be, who
in the world is Elon getting the nations
from since he's inheriting the nations?
Who's giving him the who's who's giving
the most high the the nations? Who's
giving that to him? Because he's
inheriting the nations. What do we see,
ladies and gentlemen? We see that Jesus
Jesus is the most high who sits
enthroned next to the majesty. And the
majesty says, "Thank you. And the Lord
says to he says,"The Lord says to my
Lord, "Sit at my right hand until I make
your enemies your foottool and ask of me
and I will give you the inheritance of
the nations.
I will make the I will make the nations
yours." That's Psalm 110. Why does your
scripture quote verbatim a a polytheist
eugoric text?
>> Can you show me where?
>> Here we go. So Isaiah 27 and1 Psalms
74:13 and 14 are quoted directly in from
KTU 1.5 of the Ugaritic script verbatim.
Why? You didn't you just you just said
that.
>> I already read it. I already read it to
you. You just didn't deal with it. But
I'll read it again for you. In that day,
Yahweh will punish Leviathan, the
Ugaritic word, will be Lotan. The
Leviathan, the fleeing serpent.
Leviathan, the twisting serpent. KTU 1.5
from this pagan Ugoritic text says,
"When you smite Lotan, the fleeing
serpent, finishing off the twisting
serpent, the tyrant with seven heads."
Psalm 74:14,
crushing the heads of the the seven
heads of the Leviathan. Why is this a
direct one for one quote from this
polytheist polytheistic text? It
>> doesn't necessarily sound like a one one
for one quote to me. Um, but I see a lot
of similarities there. And it would be
interesting like if you were to say like
you have the pagan Arabs who use the
term Allah uh for you know and to be the
father of you know goddesses and deities
and then Islam comes later and then uses
Allah as their one god their one deity
and so would you say that the
>> it's my turn ask I know I'm not asking a
real question. It's rhetorical. I'm
saying
>> it's not your turn to ask rhetorical
questions man. I
>> I can ask a rhetorical question because
it's not a real question for you to
answer. I'm just It's rhetorical.
>> You say it's a
>> Yeah, hold on. Wait. I got it. I got it.
I got it. I got it.
>> It's a cross exam, man.
>> Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
>> You wouldn't say that the Quran is now
quoting uh the pagan uh uh literature in
when when the Quran refers to Allah as
God, just like when the pagans before
referred to Allah as God, you wouldn't
you wouldn't say that. So, I think that
you should have the same consistency
here. Number one. Number two, this is
beautiful because even if we see same
similar concepts within ancient ancient
uh you know uh Middle Eastern theology,
we see similar concepts, that doesn't
mean that there's a copy or there's a oh
a direct quoter it's stealing from. What
we do see though is how how the biblical
authors engage with the polytheistic and
pagan theologies of the uh the Gentiles
around them and they demonstrate that
Yahweh is the true God over what they
call gods over what who they think is
mighty and and the biblical authors
place Yahweh as mighty over them. That's
what you're seeing a display here in the
Bible. If something is referred to as
Elohim, does that mean that it's God by
nature?
>> What do you mean by nature?
that it's the true God, the uh the
living God, the everlasting God, creator
of he creator of heaven and earth.
>> Is that the definition of the true God?
>> Yes. I I just answered you again. So now
>> Yeah, no problem. So yes, so no problem.
Human beings are called Elohim.
>> That's not what I asked you. I'll ask it
again. Does the Does the word Elohim
depict a god by nature just by the word
itself?
>> It can at times and at times it doesn't.
>> So by the word itself it doesn't, but
context will tell you what it's
referring to. Is that correct?
>> That's correct.
>> Okay. In Psalm 82, the Elohim that God
is judging over,
>> can you show me in Psalm 82 where they
are God by nature, gods by nature, that
they actually possess the divine
essence?
>> Yeah. What does your God call that
council?
>> Why are you asking me a question?
>> My bad. They're called They're called
the divine council, right? Uh, can you
show me that they're divine in essence
and not just in their not in just their
role because they are part of the
heavenly council? Can you show me that
they're gods by nature?
>> Does your god call them the divine
council?
>> Hold on real quick. Hold on real quick.
Nor, if it's not if that's not a
rhetorical, try to form it in a way
where you you're just making a statement
yourself and then you can ask that
during the 20.
>> No problem. Your god calls them a divine
divine. So that's the answer.
>> Does he call them divine nature or call
them the divine counsel?
He calls them divine counsel.
>> Thank you. So, uh being a divine counsel
doesn't entail the people who's or the
beings that's part of the divine counsel
as having divinity within themselves as
far as them being true God. Where in
Psalm 82 does it depict them as being
God by nature? God's by nature.
>> Clarifying question. Can you show me
nature in the Bible because I'm not
tracking it.
>> No, that's not a clarifying question.
You're playing games. Can you please
answer the question? If not, don't
answer. Just say you can't.
>> Okay, then I'll answer like this. I
haven't seen the word nature in the
Bible, so I don't know how to answer
this philosophical question. You have
it. The word nature, divine nature. No.
Okay. Uh, how much time do I have left?
>> We have one minute left.
>> One minute left. Man, you are
embarrassing yourself, man. This is this
is this is the belt boys champion,
y'all. Deuteronomy 4. Watch what it says
here. and lest you lift up your eyes to
heaven and see the sun and the moon and
the stars all the host of heaven and be
drawn away and worship them and serve
them those which Yahweh your God has
aortioned for all the peoples under the
whole heaven. So um it could be
referring to the sun, the moon and the
stars and you know the elements of the
universe and the galaxies.
>> You said that was Deuteronomy what?
>> Deuteronomy 4.
>> Deuteronomy chapter 4 verse 19.
>> Verse 19. Let's go look at that real
quick. Let's go look at that in the
heat, bro.
>> Yep.
>> One second.
>> Take your time, man. It's a slow cook,
>> bro. You've conceded that there's other
beings up in heaven with your God
throwing down lightning, man.
>> Yeah, they're not.
>> You just don't want to call by nature.
You're cook, man.
>> You can see that they're not God by
nature.
>> Ain't coming, man.
>> You can see that they're not gods by
nature. Okay.
>> All of a sudden, you don't know what
nature means. You don't know what truth.
>> I don't know what all that that Pho talk
is. All that philosophy that's not in
your Bible.
>> Like,
>> it's right here in the Bible.
>> No, it's not. You ain't shown me divine
essence once. You just made that up,
man.
You just made that up, man. And they
don't have the divine essence. Show me
that in the Bible. Uh, well, I can't.
Can you show me God throwing lightning
bolts? Uh, well, I can, but they don't
have the divine essence.
>> This is tough. Now, now, now in order
for Abu Nori, he needs the words divine
essence to be shown in the Bible for him
to understand what that is. That's
amazing.
>> Yeah. For you to tie the definition of
what a god to to that is crazy. So,
you're telling me that the basically the
Greeks are not polytheists cuz they
don't actually believe in real gods.
>> They do. Greeks
>> they are polytheist. They believe that
those that those entities are gods by
nature.
>> Oh, you just said that there's only one
nature, sir. You said there's only one
divine essence.
>> Exactly. And but according to Greek
mythology, I'm I'm not talking about
you're you're talking about Greek
mythology. In the Bible, there's only
one divine essence. There's only one God
by nature, one true God. In Greek
mythology, they believed in multiple
true gods. They believe that multiple
beings were truly God.
>> Sir, all of these beings didn't share
the same essence. You had demigods. You
had Hold on.
>> I know.
>> You're saying that the only true God is
someone who has this divine essence.
>> Correct. You had gods according to the
polytheists of the past who all had
different essences but were still gods.
You still polytheist?
>> Yes. Yes. They believed that these
multiple entities were true gods.
Multiple true gods.
>> By true gods, do you mean they shared
the same essence?
>> Meaning that they have divine essences.
That there is multiple divine essences.
>> Oh, so as long as they were some type of
divine, that was polytheism, right? No,
not some type of divine. That their
essence is divine. That their essence is
truly godhood. That's what they believed
about their multiple entities. In the
Bible, hold on. In the Bible, it does
not teach that these other entities are
truly God. That they are truly divine in
essence. It doesn't teach that. It
teaches that there's only one true God.
As Jeremiah says, as John 17 says, as 1
Corinthians 8 says, as uh Galatians
says, it says that these these things
that they worshiped and sacrificed to
are not gods.
>> Mhm. Yeah. They can come and say that
later all they want to. Okay.
>> Do you agree that there is a concept in
the Bible of God by nature?
>> In the New Testament, you just showed
us.
>> In the New Testament, you just showed us
>> Is the New Testament part of the Bible?
>> Yeah, that's fine.
>> Okay. So is that a yes? According to the
Bible, it does have a concept of God by
nature.
>> Yeah, sure.
>> Okay. So, the reason why I needed that,
>> just real fast, just very quick, does it
also have other than that in the Bible?
>> It has other concepts of the term God,
but not by nature. The reason why it was
important for you to admit this, the
Bible does have a concept of God by
nature. Is because you started off in
your opening statement, you started off
saying, "I'm not talking about gods by
like judges. I'm not talking about just
gods who have rulership or whatever. I'm
talking about gods who have power, gods
who have sovereignty, gods, you are
talking about gods by nature, actually
being gods, being actual divine beings.
And so with your concession that the
Bible does have a concept of God by
nature, it explicitly excludes
everything else other than Yahweh from
being God by nature. Your argument is
done. The debate is over. It was over a
long time ago, but it's like over again,
and now it's over again. It's over
again. It's over, bro. I don't even know
what we doing here anymore. How much
time we got left? Life.